on August the 27th 1645 the small town
of Burris and Edmonds England set a
grisly record that Dame eighteen men and
women were hanged together as witches it
was the single biggest mass execution
for witchcraft in English history and it
was all the work of one man Matthew
Hopkins was many things its have an
owner a former lawyer a dedicated
Puritan but as the people of Maurice and
Edmonds he had only one title worth
knowing and that was Witchfinder general
the son of a minister Hopkins began
plying his gruesome trade in 1645 at the
height of the first English Civil War
together with his associate John Stern
he was personally responsible for the
torture and execution of more women than
every single English witch finder in the
previous century but Hopkins as tale is
more than just a catalogue of atrocity
it's a tale of what can happen when an
entire nation succumbs to fear and mass
hysteria today we're going to examine
how one zealous man managed to corrupt
England's soul
[Music]
when Matthew Hopkins was born in Wenham
Suffolk probably in 1620 it was into a
world that was alive with superstition a
king was on the throne King James the
first who didn't just believe in witches
but had literally written the book on
them called demonology Britain's fastest
growing religious movement Puritanism
took it for granted that Satan himself
walked the byways and the country lanes
of England Hopkins this meant a
childhood that was practically drowning
in superstition his father John was a
Puritan minister who preached fire and
brimstone as was his uncle and one of
his brothers it's likely they even had a
copy of demonology blowing around the
house we say likely here because there's
a lot we actually don't know about
Matthew Hopkins as early life while
centuries of legends claim that he did
this all that the historical record is
actually pretty sparse take his
education there's some evidence that he
may have gone to Holland to finish his
schooling just as the some evidence he
may have trained as a lawyer but we're
gonna be honest with you and simply say
that we just don't know maybe all of
that is true but maybe none of it is
what is true is that it is harder passed
away at some points likely around 1635
come 1640 Matthew moved 10 miles down
the roads and Manningtree in Essex local
lore has it that he purchased the thorn
in in nearby miss Lee but really that's
just another gas but it's here that the
guesswork are finally ends we know that
Hopkins was in Manningtree by the end of
1640 we also know that he was around on
19 or 20 years old and that's important
because 1640 was the year that the
peaceful England of Hopkins's youth
finally fractured into a billion jagged
pieces it was time for the first English
Civil War
if you've watched our video on Oliver
Cromwell and modesty aside does make a
useful crib sheet for this entire period
you'll know that 1640 ended with a
Scottish army occupying the north of
England and King Charles the first being
forced to call the new Parliament's to
raise taxes
okay now the ins and outs of this don't
really matter for today's story but the
upshot is that this led to something
called the Long Parliament which led to
something called the grand remonstrance
which in 1642 led to Charles deciding to
crush Parliament's in a war and look I I
know we're really missing out a lot of
stuff here don't have too much of a go
at me in the comments this is really
just a super condensed timeline in order
to give you just some background
information now the war was really hard
on England as civil wars tend to be
local courts were suspended in many
regions and law and order it kind of
broke down in place of all this came
Hammond fuel shortages and biting
poverty places like the East of England
where Hopkins lived were particularly
hard-hit much of the East was staunchly
Puritan and pro Parliament which was a
huge problem when nearby Oxford was the
base of the Kings ante Puritan army to
use a crude analogy living in Essex
during the dark days of the war would
have been like living in Poland
shortly after Hitler annex
Czechoslovakia you know the hammer is
gonna fall you just don't know when and
that waiting could send men mad
men like Sir Harbottle Grimstone back in
1640 the livestock on sir Grimm's dunes
vast a state in a state that included
Hopkins's new home had begun to be
plagued by mysterious illnesses as the
ongoing war worsened a situation the
local peasantry turned to superstition
in order to explain things before long
they were certain that it had to be the
work of a witch and in 1645 they finally
identified her Elizabeth Clark was an
elderly widow living on sir grim stones
lands them arts a lynch mob of villagers
presented her to Sir grim stone as the
source of all his woes like the good
Christian he was sir grins didn't
recommended Elizabeth Clark for trial
[Music]
all right so at this point we do need to
take a quick leap back in time because I
want to give you some background
information on which trials in England's
because a it's super interesting and B
because it will help you understand how
terrifyingly unique Hopkins was prior to
the era were talking about which hunting
hadn't really been a thing in England in
the medieval period witches were
actually seen as healers and pillars of
their communities it wasn't until 1563
under Elizabeth the first that the bill
against conjuration and witchcraft and
sorcery and enchantments made witchcraft
illegal even then it was barely illegal
the first major witch trial in 1566
found all three defendants guilty and
sentenced them to just a single year in
prison that's right no torture no
burning at the stake just 12 months in
the knick now we need to be clear that
English women were executed for
witchcraft in this period unlike on the
continent though their deaths were
closer to lynchings local magistrates
would get caught up in a panic and sign
a death warrant only to be later
punished by their superiors for the
incredulous fools executions weren't
government policy unless the witch was
using her supposed powers to commit
other capital crimes like murder now
that all changed when James the first
ascended to the throne on March the 24th
1603 Elizabeth first breathed her last
in the chilly rooms of Richmond Palace
barely was she cold before her successor
James the first was ramming auntie witch
legislation through Parliament's James
the first was obsessed with rich crafts
in 1589 had been on a boat that nearly
sank in a storm that was blamed on
witches and the experience sent him just
a little cuckoo in 1597 he published
demonology the witch finding book that
James Hopkins had kept lying around
Matthew's childhood home in 1604 James
the first turns this personal obsession
into legal reality parliament passed the
witchcraft statute which made the very
act of using witchcraft rather than the
spells effects capsule offense if that
sounds like splitting hairs the results
suggest otherwise eight years after the
bill passed ten women were hanged in
pendel for witchcraft four years later
another nine were sent to the gallows in
Leicester by the time you get to
Elizabeth Clark's trial in 1645 witch
trials had become a fact of life in
England
only remarkable thing about them was how
comparatively restrains they were
remember this was the era of the worst
burg witch trials went up to 600 witches
were burned alive in Germany against
such mass slaughter nine or ten being
hanged was pretty mild unfortunately
though things wouldn't be mild for much
longer
back in mannington 1645 Matthew Hopkins
had gotten wind of Clarks impending
trial for whatever reason something
about this news lit a fire in his solve
burns like the fires of hell despite
having no training and no legal standing
Hopkins decided it was his duty to get
involved with Clark's prosecution it was
a decision that would very soon lead to
the bloodiest witch panic in English
history
in a 1647 book the discovery of witches
Matthew Hopkins would claim his witch
hunting career began in 1644 however all
evidence suggests as that was here with
Elizabeth Clark in March of 1645 that he
really got into witch finding no one is
sure of the exact timeline but it seems
that Hopkins was approached by a man
tenures his senior named John Stern
originally from Lowe's in Suffolk how
exactly they got talking is unknown but
it soon transpired that Stern shared
Hopkins's sharply-defined view of good
and evil
together they agreed to make Clark
confess to her sins at this point in
English history torture it was illegal
to elicit a confession suspected witches
would be monitored by Watchers to see if
they summoned any familiars or started
zooming around on broomsticks or
something like that Clark had been
watched for several days now and so far
nothing it happens that was until
Hopkins and stern showed up despite
having no legal authority to do so
Hopkins and stern convinced the Watchers
to turn Clark's interrogation over to
them they took her to the faun in and
what happens next is shrouded in mystery
popkins would later claim that they
witnessed Clark call her familiars imps
in the animal form to the inn including
a demonic bunny rabbit named of sugar
hands no we're not making this up more
likely Hopkins and stern they tortured
the poor old woman either way the result
was the same
Clark confessed to being a witch and she
started naming other witches as well
armed with these new names stern and
Hopkins approached the Earl of Hardwick
who was presiding over Clark's trial
impressed by the young men's initiative
Hardwick gave Stern an official warrants
to finds more witches in mannington
Hawkins he was made his assistant it
wouldn't be long before their roles were
reversed though over the next few weeks
Hopkins and stern conducted their
inquiries the five women named by Clark
were all taken in and interrogated until
they too confessed and gave up more
names within no time at all the witch
finders have jailed 23 women and
mannington was in the grip of a
full-blown witch panic Puritan writer
Nahum Iowa Langton recorded the whole
thing including the lurid testimony of
Rebecca West who'd been jailed by
Hopkins alongside her mother Anne West
claims that she had been forced to have
sex with the devil and that only a
mother's death could save her from sate
spell the jury obliged by having an
hanged by the end of the Essex trials 18
women had been hanged including
Elizabeth clock further four more had
died in jail only Rebecca West who'd
sacrificed her own mother was finally
set free it was the deadliest witch
panic to have ever hit England even if
Hopkins and Stern had never tried
another witch the Essex trials would
still be famous buoyed by his success in
Manningtree perhaps enjoying the
newfound celebrity Hopkins bestowed upon
himself the title of which find general
armed with Hardwick's warranty and stern
headed east following in the wake of the
shocking news of Clarke's execution it
was this news that became the spark that
would turn the East of England into an
inferno
in December 1643 the provost marshal of
the parliamentarian Eastern Association
commissioned William dowsing to destroy
all non Puritan icons in Suffolk dowsing
took to the job like an extremist duck
to water way into 1645 he rampaged
across the east burning churches
vandalizing icons and encouraging
Puritan extremism eventually dousing
zealotry got so frightening that Oliver
Cromwell personally stripped him of his
commission by then the damage it was
done dozens of towns across Suffolk had
been reduced to wrecks their populations
either cowed or swept up in religious
fervor it was these people who two years
later would call upon the Witchfinder
general as they left behind the dead of
Manningtree and ventured into Suffolk in
1645 Hopkins and Stern charted a course
that took them to many of the town's
dowsing had previously swept through
it's a move straight from the modern
extremist playbook identify a person or
community already damaged by extremism
like dowsing smashing of icons and
pushed them even further into madness
just as Isis did on the war-torn plains
of Iraq Hopkins and Stern soon found an
audience in dowsing was ruined villages
the PEZ modus operandi it was simple as
they traveled the witch finders would
let villagers know that they were in the
area
the villagers responded by inviting them
in yep they really didn't like them like
a pair of misogynistic vampires Hopkins
and Stern never entered a victim's home
without an invite in normal times this
would have ensured their crackpot
adventure and as soon as it began but
well these were not normal times people
were afraid afraid that the Kings army
would kill them that their children
would starve and that they would freeze
to death in the winter in another
historical context that fear might have
been turned on Jews or illegal
immigrants or any other outside a group
in England's of 1645 it was turned on
women once invited into a village
Hopkins and Stern set to work on
suspected witches unlikely thumbscrew
happy sadists in Europe Hopkins as
interrogation methods wouldn't serve
looked out of place in a CIA handbook
victims were made to sit absolutely
still without sleep for days on end
others were locked in isolation and
denied food or anything but water yell
others were made to exercise for hours
and hours every day until they were
ready to
at the end of all this psychological
torture the accused they nearly always
confessed Hopkins then force them to
name more witches in the village who
would in turn confess and so on and so
forth that's not to say that the stories
you've heard about Hopkins aren't true
he really did test if some women were
witches by tying them up and throwing
them into rivers those that drowns they
were innocent and those that floated had
magic powers and they were executed for
all this bloodshed Hopkins and stone and
anywhere between six pounds and 23
pounds per village at the high ends
that's roughly equivalent to 5,000
pounds or $6,500 today it said that
Hopkins made a thousand pounds during
his career as a witch finder at a time
when the average laborers wage was a
mere six pence per day death in short it
made Matthew Hopkins filthy rich not
that he in Stern actually hung around
for the death part that confession
elicited the Witchfinder general and his
assistant would vanish into the night
leaving the accused to their fates and
what fates these were in August of 1645
an 80 year old minister called John
Lau's was forced to run on the spot
without sleep until he collapsed from
exhaustion on the 27th of that month 18
women and men were hanged together
outside barrese and Edmunds the worst
mass execution of any English witch scat
and yet that's right men were killed as
witches too Hopkins was responsible for
the execution of between 17 and 20 men
for witchcraft during his career
including three husbands who were killed
alongside their wives but let's not kid
ourselves gender was an important factor
in determining if you survived a meeting
with Matthew Hopkins in that same space
of time when he killed 20 men Hopkins
sent an estimated 200 women to the
gallows in September of 1645 the
Witchfinder general committed his most
notorious act as the dark night drew in
Hopkins and Stern arrived in Ipswich
there they tried and convicted Mary
Lakeland in a shocking break with
tradition rather than hanging her they
decided to burn her alive as the black
smoke coiled into the sky over rush Muir
Heath Hopkins pocketed his fee and left
perhaps he heard Mary Lakeland screams
and felt sorry for her but perhaps they
made him feel good this was the foul
this day in the history of English witch
hunting thankfully it would also be one
of the last
so it's something you might not have
expected during this whole gynae side
thing Hopkins and Stern hadn't exactly
been hiding from the authorities the new
UC has reported the Hopkins may have
been paid for his work by official
government sources whether that's true
or not there's no denying the
Witchfinder general soon came to the
attention of parliament back in August
of 1945 Hopkins s conviction of John
Lowe's that old guy that he forced to
run up and down until he collapsed had
resulted in a witch panic in barrese and
Edmunds that eventually saw a hundred
people jailed at Hopkins had his way all
100 of them would have been executed but
word of the gigantic witch trial at leak
to Parliament it was simply too big to
be credible so Parliament send their own
people out to retry everyone convicted
by Hopkins this time the trials would be
more careful they would be less tainted
by bias which is why on August the 27th
only 18 witches were hanged at Maurice
and Edmonds rather than the 100 that
Hopkins had hoped for of course
hanging 18 people for made-up magic is
still deranged but here's the thing
Parliament's witch hunters were a model
of sanity compared to Hopkins and Stern
in light of the near miss of Maurice and
Edmunds many MPs began to wonder if
Hopkins was actually a bigger danger
than the witches that he was finding it
helps that by fall of 1645 the
conditions that had allowed mass
hysteria to flourish they were on the
wane the Battle of Naseby in June that
year had seen the remaining royalist
forces mostly crushed the war was now
winding down and with it the famine
hunger and fear that had driven the
witch panics was as well as 1646 dawns
the tide of public opinion had
decisively turned against the witch
finders the Puritan minister John gall
published a pamphlet that attacked
Hopkins in no uncertain terms for the
slaughter that he was inflicting on the
countryside
ghoul was someone who actually believed
in witches but even he could see that
the Witchfinder general was XANA control
Hopkins tried to fight back he wrote all
the chilling note threatening to come
look for witches in his area if gahl
ever criticized him again he and stern
they stepped up their visits to villages
but the game it was already up on April
the 27th 1646 Charles the first was
forced to flee Oxford after
to parliamentary forces although the
king would escape being taken into
custody for some weeks the first English
Civil War it was over not long after
Parliament summoned Hopkins and stern
accusing them of the illegal use of
torture Hopkins was now famous but not
as a savior over the Puritan faith
rather has say likely charlatans who'd
sent countless women to their deaths by
August 16 46 Hopkins has credibility
with the public it was shot villagers no
longer sought him out
the powerful no longer defended his work
possibly scared Parliament's might try
them in turn the Witchfinder general
discarded his phony title and retired
back to Manningtree his entire witch
hunting career had lasted less than 18
months still Hopkins had his blood money
and he was respected by some of the most
zealous Puritans thanks to his
reputation he was able to publish his
book the discovery of witches in 1647
when the first editions reach New
England's they sparked off a series of
witch panics that would culminate in the
infamous 1692 Salem witch trials what
the Hopkins would live to see the last
grisly fulfilment of his legacy in
August of 16 47 at the age of just 26 or
27 Matthew Hopkins keeled over in
Manningtree and died while legend says
that he was tried as a witch using his
own methods and executed the mundane
reality appears to be that tuberculosis
carried him off yes even as Hopkins died
the world he helped create was already
fading
[Music]
by the end of 1648 the vast majority of
English women accused of witchcraft
weren't being acquitted even when the
second and third English Civil Wars blew
up followed by Oliver Cromwell's Puritan
dictatorship nothing like the witch
panics of 1645
took hold again 40 years later in March
of 1680 for Elisha Mullins became the
last person to be put to death for
witchcraft in English history there
would be more trials including an
infamous one in 1717 but never again
with the results in a verdict of
execution now let's flash forward to
1735 a full 90 years after Matthew
Hopkins as ghoulish Spectre last roams
the English countryside the creator
Robert Walpole was the Prime Minister
and these superstitions of the 17th
century had given way to the scientific
curiosity of the 18th that year
Parliament passed the witchcraft act it
repealed all previous witch laws and all
punishments for witchcraft
instead it penalized pretending to be a
witch for profit or to influence others
think about that for a second within
living memory Matthew Hopkins had
slaughtered more than 200 women for
being witches now the law stated that
such a thing was impossible the
witchcraft was nothing more than a
pretense a humbug we like to think that
that news sent Matthew Hopkins rolling
in his grave finally on June the 13th
1782 Swiss executioner's dragged and a
Goldie out to a field and lopped off her
head the Bloods that patted down onto
the grass would be the last blood that
would ever be spilled in Europe's witch
hunts over the previous three centuries
over 200,000 women had perished at the
hands of the continents inquisitors 300
years of misogynistic murder had finally
come to an end but the story it doesn't
quite stop there in 1921 gardeners were
doing some work on a house in the
villages and OSA thin Essex when they
found a pair of female skeletons dating
from the era of the English witch trials
the two unknown women had iron rivets
driven through their joints to stop them
rising from the grave it was a chilling
visceral reminder of Hopkins and his
methods transported forward to the 20th
century even now traces of his
superstitious well if you still linger
over the countryside in local Hills and
forgotten Heath's named for the tortures
that he inflicted there or the helpless
women who died under them
Hopkins may be gone but his legacy lives
on the next time you hear spooky tales
of
growls or maybe someone dressed as a
witch for Halloween remember to spare a
thought for all of the women who died at
the hands of England's Witchfinder
general so I hope you found the video
interesting if you did please do give us
a thumbs up below and don't forget to
subscribe we got brand new videos just
like this several times a week and if
you're looking for something else to
watch right now why not check out one of
our other videos linked to on the screen
now I've also got another channel top
10s find that linked in the description
below and as always thank you for
watching
[Music]